let's get right down to it what are we
talking about all right well the first
thing to get out of the way is this is a
long oh yes wait Carson block like
something I know say it ain't so but
fatherhood's change this right when you
told us that you're not a ninja assassin
you're not a ninja assassin I love
everything it's a we're um we're long
company traded in France called bellari
all right Oh Laurie it's a holding
company and the reason that we're long
bellari
it's actually really the mirror image of
a lot of our shorts in that it has a
very opaque corporate structure but in
this case the opacity actually is
created a huge arbitrage opportunity so
people don't investors don't understand
really what this corporate structure
does and it looks like Bowl RA has about
2.5 billion shares outstanding because
of the this corporate structure there's
so much circular ownership that
effectively you have all of this
Treasury stock that and that's not being
under accounting rules excluded so the
true shares outstanding we estimate are
really about 1.1 billion so that means
that the public instead of owning about
25 percent of this company actually owns
about 50 to 53 percent of it so if you
look at it on a net asset value per
share basis which you would do with the
holding company that effectively more
than doubles what the net asset value
per share is so this is something that
you know we think is worth at least 850
euro let's just back it up let's just
slow this down it's a holding company
for us how exactly do you unlock the
value here mmm how about we spell it
first for everybody
sure vol L o re yes and it's run by a
French billionaire yes Vincent bellari
who actually has he's known as the Carl
Icahn of France and then you know Fran
Europe has a reputation for not having
activist investors I mean this guy's
been throwing very sharp elbows for
about three decades
I mean he's you know he's tussled with
Lazard he's on the board of Vivendi now
very impressive investor